this is going to be the lightning round
hopefully the early stuff didn't present
you with too many problems first it
wykel's log base 2 of X plus 1
it's so similar to microwave a 2x with
what difference whatever you like to
recognize that this thing is giving your
shift which direction is it going you
it's going up right
so therefore previously we had our
points of scale like we're not points
the scale just coordinate so we went
through like this here this was 1 comma
0 right and also this point over here
which was to copper one to remember that
well I'm going to take both of these
guys and I'm going to really look 1
right so this point here is going to be
1 1 right that's right
hey Bronk and then this one over here as
I move it up one will be at was looking
at one it was right there - 102 - thank
you ok but as you can see when you move
that upwards like that your x intercept
is going to change now you can work out
the exact and intercept really easily
how do you usually work out x intercept
y believe you let white with your so you
come over here oh come on you come over
here and you say well if Y was 0 here
right then you're getting log base 2 of
X plus 1 equals 0 right well can you
solve this for me what do I do I'm going
to subtract 1 from both sides
and now in order to solve for X I'm
going to turn it into an exponential
equation not want equation what
exponential equation will be so that's
why and you can always see it right you
see where my points are going to go
you're going to intersect with the
x-axis at top right so then when you go
ahead join up the dots and what's you
man okay
you will then notice I've got X and y
intercepts
I'm not going to collide with the y-axis
I want to play the scale
where's the accent
we'll see ugh
where was the asymptote for force zero
it's just that being more specific the
big waters acting for everything right
so it used to be here and the whole idea
of the error is indicators goes on
forever
what if you take a vertical line that
goes on forever and you move it up one
unit how different this along its up not
different law difficulties name so
therefore noise water and therefore 11
secondly okay let's do the recipes a
little bit quicker be y equals 1 ways to
lift plus what everything inside there
it's not a vertical shift anymore this
plus water is actually mucking around
with the wine this plus one is luckier
over the X what direction am I going to
go to left okay so the same to quick to
scale I mentioned before which used to
be here and here I'm now going to be
here in here I'm actually going to pass
through the origin right and also pass
through one one okay but this time
you're given a vertical line now it has
moved where is it now you're 8 equals
negative think it's set of actually to
the left hand side and that you get the
idea there you go
that's all you do they make sense you
fold okay now I'm going to stick
straight over to this one which is going
to 5 now that was five I wonder how many
of you notice you can kind of be a bit
too clever for yourself on this one
you're like what do I do with that x
squared oh wait I know fancy lot wars
that can relate that to what would this
equivalent suit if you use log laws to
manipulate what would you get you get 2
log base 2 of X now this is tricky
what should it think with me last week
we talked that domain reg we talked
about it in some depth tell me well the
domain a range of let's just do this one
the domain range of this function
X has to be ground zero and reach all we
values they're all fine now that's all
fine but when you look at this guy here
and you compared to this one here their
domains have changed numerically
everything is the same if you've taken
to any s value life like that x equals 5
that's because I want 32 you can that's
basic too right
you're going to get our log base 2 of 32
square is log base 2 of a thousand 24
this is Julian numbers in your head so
often right this is 10 when you have a
look at two log base 2 of with the
number I just say 32 right well this is
2 times 5 which is 10 right so
numerically everything is the same but
what this function the original one
before much with the wallboard
this function has a domain that is
broader than this one what's the
difference
many ones here this example which is 32
from red what would happen if I tried
native boot well if I put it into the
original function which is square right
what's going to happen just going to get
this right you see one diamond students
to see why maybe if those two times
negative two is there were going to be a
constant on but what happens when you
put it into your new adjusted function
you're going to have this what are they
this is not defined because look it's
outside disease so therefore one since I
look like last thing that you can do
there's the side don't you stood and
then there's the sign
not because guess what guess what what
kind of symmetry does this function have
what kind of picture you expect to have
a period zero you look it's an even
function well thank you everyone